you like to scream a lot in the ring I  do like to scream what is that all about  well it's just like a primal scream and  a mitt you know it's very it makes me  feel good makes me feel confident you  know just to let it out let all that  anger out right so I feel like I should  show you my stream you're really  annoying okay but if I do it then you  guys have to do it too all right okay  sure okay you have to try it oh yeah I  will  yeah a lot of primal energy in here  straight from the ovaries oh okay I'm  not I'm not I'm not desensitized we're  just an okay yeah yeah we all goes at  the same time same time okay  dirt I'm gonna do it I promise I won't  put you in my submission if you don't do  it oh then I better do it  we got the lousy astray I'll put you on  the ground and lick you  I'm gonna scream alright one  [Applause]